[Musique]
bonjour pour commencer je citerai
françois mitterrand qui disait pour dire
oui il faut pouvoir dire non perdu
pardon est tombée aujourd'hui je reçois
le champion du monde de ni oui ni non
c'est michael bonjour bonjour alors vous
êtes le champion du monde en titre en
tête
je répondrai par l'affirmative d'accord
vous savez qu'on peut se parler
normalement là etes-vous le champion du
monde ni oui ni non
oui ou non leur réponse n'est pas
négative bien au contraire
d'accord mais on joue pas en fait là
vous avez conscience de ces éléments
donc vous voulez bien qu'on se parle
comme des personnes normales une journée
fort probable ok donc je vois que vous
êtes mariés c'est ça et vous avez deux
enfants brandon et spiro vous les aimez
brandon énormément spirou exactement
pareil ok donc on va faire une pause
je parle d'une pause dans l'interview
parce que je pense qu'on s'est mal
compris en fait là on est hors
compétition
j'ai pas si vous avez compris le but de
ça moi je suis un être humain qui veux
juste parler avec vous faites un effort
ok j'ai compris vous vous étiez encore
dans le même temps vraiment en mode
compétition
est ce que je me suis dit on s'en sort
pas les facultés bonbons on y va on y va
officiellement donc vous êtes mariés
effectivement n'oubliez pas en journée
et vous vous êtes mariés ou exacte elle
est jolie elle est à mon goût et la
vôtre magnifix de ce que voulait savoir
faire du tout avez vous un animal un
labrador c'est un chien sa dette il pas
c'est ce qui se dit dans 30 millions
d'amis aimez-vous les animaux seulement
les volatiles c'est un beau projet
oiseaux sans doute
l'aviez-vous compris vous avez l'air
tendu c'est inexact je suis concentré
ses différents mondes en totale maîtrise
verbal donc on peut continuer
l'interview tout à fait continuer mes
interviews
alors comment ça se passe
par mon grand-père ok on va arrêter
l'interview du coup vous pouvez couper
michael on repousse vous allez rejoindre
votre famille et vous vous occupez de
l'onf est simple oui c'est le champion
du monde de creux dans mon corps oui tu
as dit oui le mec boxe thaï et papilles
est mort je perds pied
la semaine prochaine nous recevrons oui
oui le personnage préféré des enfants
affirmatif ça va quand père du petit
temps four si tu creuses comme son grand
père tu as perdu des tricks aujourd'hui
toi ton titre est ton papy twitter
d'athus voir vous passez une matraque et
conquis là